j'aime juste la façon dont une grande communauté peut venir
à un endroit et se rassembler et s'amuser
[Musique] [
Musique]
je cherche juste à célébrer la guerre des étoiles
avec d'autres fans et nous pouvons tous nous
réunir surtout depuis la pandémie
donc c'est agréable de  être dans un endroit avec
des gens qui aiment la guerre des étoiles
[Musique] [
Musique]
cette année, nous avons beaucoup de spectacles qui
sortent nous avons andorr sort kenobi qui
sort ce vendredi
peut-être quelques regards ahsoka mais c'est la
première célébration en dehors du
skywalker saga donc c'est beaucoup de nouveau
contenu
[Musique]
vous